[Music]
crows represent order security safety
Batman gave up on us the beds not coming
back
something's up I've every where
hello said Alice shall we believe the
crows would protect us do you copy
Sophie's missing I thought you should
know hey Dad
we're gonna find her then let me help
bad idea
where'd you get this what happened to
staying out of it is there something
you'd like to report to your squad
ticket ran in without proper backup I do
not want her getting in the way
[Music]
curiouser and curiouser
what do you want I need you to send your
father a message you all I have laughter
Kate and I don't want to lose you too
[Music]
Wayne security you all my boss a new
door
your boss is my cousin you don't want to
go do that you're seriously not suppose
to know what's down there so I have this
thing with rolls
[Music]
[Music]
I need you to fix his suit the suit is
literal perfection it will be when it
fits a woman
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're a female Bruce Wayne awesome
hilarious handsome
[Music]
they think I'm him
[Music]
I'm not about to let a man take credit
for a woman's work
you
you